oui bonsoir bonsoir juste si je peux me
permettre je me suis entraîné toute la
semaine pour l'heure pour un ping pong
comme moi j'ai chopé un pub où j'ai
étudié vos yeux j'ai vu que le revers un
vrai pays fondée sur la mini table et le
nom sur la grande bons amis et moi la
sabam et mallarmé une grande table comme
ça mais j'adore
[Musique]
aulas
alors tu vois
yoann je l'aimé bien moi je suis pas tes
petits copains de l'aquarium
allez c'est parti on y va à l'essai les
vacances merci à mourir mais mes
vacances c'est les vacances en italie
alors moi je vais jouer comme ça
apparemment pas ouvrir la table tu as
tout voulez que je fasse les maisons de
les baisser
sinon c'est là que c'est là que ça
compte deux minutes c'est la première
fois qu'on va s'en tenir
on est vraiment les seuls remèdes ça te
dérange on joue comme ça c'est tout des
roches sauf un mur noir et les mecs ça
sert à rien de faire ça en fait voilà
voilà
[Applaudissements]
allez on y va
c'est parti l'enquêteur inquiéter
raquette
allez c'est parti qu'est ce qui est en
jeu qu'est ce qui est en jeu est-ce que
qu'est ce qui te ferait plaisir comme
cadeau alors moi j'ai une devant
particulière vas-y j'aimerais ont fait
une chose si je gagne je suis
chroniqueur un jour je perds je fais le
ménage une semaine c'est fait genia la
maison c'est amusant on part comme à la
maison
c'est fait en combien de points je vais
pas me dis pas 21 parce que j'ai quand
même j'ai à prendre ou à laisser après
la pause sinon aller 5-5
enfin une petite bonne entre noël et une
balle et que tu joues vachement bien
très près par le ballet espagnol
non mes frères on s'en va pas te
présenter devant cyril hanouna comme ça
ils écoutent pas quand il parle il a
essayé tout en fumée rien sur la balle
est bon à vous écoute pas faire comme
hier il aimerait tous avoir la balle
d'entraînement sa démarche
ouais bravo
bon tu es proche de ping pong barak
non non baal et un jour il a glissé j'ai
entendu c'est la balle d'échauffement il
ya deux semaines on a laissé passer donc
je sers moi j'ai gagné là-bas mais vrai
c'est emballant bravo aux débats elle
est belle la france ont fait ping pong
et les boîtes ce soir pour bon allez
tout est filmé un je vous rappelle bhl à
2 0 elle touche à touche hélas pas
touchés n'a pas douché la rétine
je vous passerai pas si chouette ou là
j'adore ça allait tomber dans le piège
de m doit on n'a pas fini là je pense en
attente de jeu on n'est pas d'accord à
leur mission celle des profs de ping
pong de tennis à céline on passait rien
j'ai étudié le jeu je sais que leur
verse pas trop ça me travaillait au
revers
2 des tudors le des tunnels regard des
autres mois déstabiliser la guerre
psychologique 3 2 sera concentrée la
medal race à l'aquarium
je suis athée petit copain de boîte de
nuit
l'idée de la balle tu vois juste une
petite question
oui ça fait combien d'années que tu as
remarqué points à ce que je retiens les
2 0 a donné des belles serpillière
allez je me dis tu veux obtenir mon
chéri ou bien tu seras chroniqueur d'un
jour dans ses coups du plus apte alors
là choix de vie parce que ça fait
plaisir mousse éric massé sur et bien
sûr le ménage c'est moi qui vais le
faire tomber dans le sens je veux c'est
la victoire merci